el presidente mexicano y el instituto
nacional electoral ya han tenido varios
choques especialmente cuando el ine como
se llama este organismo se negó en
principio a realizar el referendo
revocatorio que proponía el mismo
presidente alegando falta de recursos se
puede entonces entender esta propuesta
de reforma como una retaliación del
mandatario
sin duda alguna es una manera de demoler
el instituto nacional electoral que
tanto y tan buenos resultados ha dado en
las elecciones que ha manejado y ha
controlado
precisamente gracias al ine el el
presidente logró la victoria en 2018 que
esto pareciera olvidársele pero yo creo
que esta reforma que se llama electoral
es mucho más profunda que una reforma
electoral en primer lugar nosotros como
país federalista estamos con esta
iniciativa borrando el pacto federal y
centralizando en un nuevo instituto la
totalidad de las funciones que les
corresponden a los estados federados en
segundo lugar está cambiando la forma de
gobierno de los ayuntamientos para poner
un límite de los concejales que tienen
cada uno de los ayuntamientos en tercer
lugar está borrando la liga que existe
entre los electores y los diputados o
senadores de mayoría relativa para
volver todo de representación
proporcional con lo que los partidos
políticos adquieren una mayor
representatividad fortaleza y poder que
serían los dueños de la democracia con
esto me iríamos hacia una radicalización
de la partidocracia y no de una
democracia electoral entonces se cambia
la forma de gobierno de órganos locales
se centralizan más poderes y funciones
en el gobierno federal o central se
desaparece el instituto nacional
electoral empieza a tomar forma la idea
de hacer consultas con una presión
política a las autoridades y por otra
parte se modifican las dos más de 2500
ayuntamientos que existen en la
república y se modifican también el
número de diputados y de senadores y
desaparece el digamos la liga con los
electores
si quiero profundizar en un punto que
usted mencionó porque usted habla de la
centralización que tendría este
organismo electoral y precisamente el
ine se creó en los 90 como un órgano
autónomo para quitar el control de las
elecciones a los gobiernos del partido
revolucionario institucional el pri en
ese sentido esta reforma usted cree que
le daría más autonomía al organismo
electoral o no
para nada la verdad es que el presidente
está en contra de todo lo que sean
organismos autónomos
él quiere que todo el poder circule
alrededor de su persona y realmente la
administración pública misma federal ha
sido de alguna manera borrada para darle
un rango protagónico exagerado al
titular del ejecutivo lo que va contra
el propósito federalista y democrático
que se había construido en méxico
durante los últimos 25 años y usted
mencionó que esta reforma también
eliminaría a algunos legisladores
concretamente a los de representación
proporcional es decir que el número de
diputados en la cámara pasaría de 500 a
300 y los senadores pasarían de 128 a
sólo 96 cuáles serían las consecuencias
de esto hay algo no es que elimine los
de representación proporcional- teníamos
un régimen mixto elimina todos para
dejar exclusivamente representación
proporcional- pura entonces uno va a
votar por partido y el partido va a
decidir quiénes van y en qué orden van
los diputados o los senadores
alcaldes ya ya no elige el elector elige
el partido político y uno vota por
partido es la representación
proporcional pura que es la que están
estableciendo en esta iniciativa de la
constitución de reforma constitucional